chân sự thật đăng sông yên lời quần cáo của mình sĩ.
Bởi vì người ơi, muốn tại một cao là mua này rất không,
đường gè rữ lại như các bạn cảm ơn.
Bản có bao giờ thức mất tại sao mình đã dành hàng giờ có dự,
dùng đủ lại nó chất nông nặng mà nhà về sinh.
Đặc biệt là buồn cầu, vẫn nhìn trong uống và còn ảm người có chứ không.
Sức thật là, nhiều sần phẩm thúc trường chỉ làm sách về mặt tạm thời mà không dịch được tận có phía quận,
nhưng nhìn chính kê ra mà bám và mùi hồi.
Nhưng gần đây, một dẻ pháp ủng dụ con người đủ phá đang được rất nhiều gia đình về tiết dùng.
Đây chỉ là chá từ dựa đáng xe ra.
Chỉ cần đủ chức thức dụng dịch lên các mề mặt cần làm sách từ bồn cầu,
là các buồn truyền sản cạnh nó bị sống dầu.
Không cần tụng xí kì cọ, chỉ cần đợi tự năm đến mi phút,
các hạn nâng sẻ tự đồng phá hỡ câu chút của vệ bẩn đường đầu.
Được đến người dùng hại lòng nước không chỉ là khả năng tẩy sẽ tán ăn,
mà còn là mình muốn đào dự nhiệm, hát tạm phương về đau đồ khó thử.
Giờ đây, việc sọn sẻ nhà biệt xí khu còn lần nữa ăn ủng,
mà cho đến nhận và ăn tẩn thương cho xíc quay cả ra đi.
Đừng đến những vết bẩn đồng phương bùi lòng bạn mệt mò,
hãy chẳng hệ ngay sẻ pháp làm sách thông minh.
Hàng chuẩn, UTN, mua hây tệ đây.